[Music]
Welcome, welcome you all to this launch
and learn. I hope you are enjoying
launch right now that the conference
brought you. Um we are going to be
talking about our recent uh product that
we announced at Heroku which is the
Heroku manage inference and agents or
part of the Heroku AI offering and we
will be talking about the fundamentals
of building agentic applications with
this service. This is not a session.
This is a workshop. So if you want to
follow along just bring your laptop. You
only need a browser. you are not going
to install anything in your computer. I
swear that is going to be uh easy to
follow along. Also, this content is
going to be available for you if you
want to continue learning at home and
and having access to the Heroku platform
during the event and the weekend.
So initially uh we are going to do the
setup while you get ready by signing up
to an Aroa account or if you already
have an Aroa account you can just get
access into the platform. I will give
you a link for you to follow. Then my
friend here is going to give you an
overview of what we release and then we
will go and do the hands on. My name is
Julian Duki. I'm a principal developer
advocate for here I am with Anush. Yeah.
Hi, my name is Anush. I work as a
product manager for Heroku AI. Uh thank
you everyone for joining us. Very
excited to talk to you guys as well as
walk you through how simple Heroku is of
course and let's get started. You can
join the workshop Heroku AI channel in
the AI engineers lack workspace. There I
share the slides and some links. Also,
this is the QR code that is going to
take you to the workshop site. So, in
the workshop site, you are going to find
a link that has the content and a form
when you enter your EOU account email.
If you already have an EO account, just
enter your email that you use to sign up
to EOKU. If you don't have an EO
account, go ahead, sign up for one. You
don't need to put like any credit card
information. And with that form, you are
going to get access to AOKU. You will be
able to deploy applications, use our
services during the duration of this
week. If you have any problems with the
signup process, let us know. We are here
to help. And this is a followalong
workshop. What are we going to do is
deploy uh Jupyter notebook to Heroku and
then we are going to load all of the
workshop contents into this Jupyter
notebook. And from there I will take you
uh with the workshop material. So let's
take a picture of this. Also make sure
you join the ESL channel. There is the
information in there. And while you are
doing the setup, my friend Anush here is
going to give give you an overview of
Heroku AI and what we release. Okay. Um
thank you for joining us friends. U how
many of you are familiar with Heroku?
Have you used Heroku before? Show of
hands. Oh, nice. So, um to set the
stage,
this is the most exciting time to be
building right now and especially
building with AI.
And this point has come before, right?
There have been inflection points with
technology that have fundamentally
changed the way we build things. There
was the internet, there was the cloud,
there were web apps and now there's AI.
Previously, when Arku started, we took a
similar challenge. People wanted to
build and deploy their apps, especially
with Ruby on Rails, but it was hard. It
was hard to operate it. It was hard to
deploy it. It was hard to scale it.
Heroku made that super simple with get
pusher heroku main and a whole new host
of developers could easily build, push
and scale their apps. We are doing a
similar thing right now where we have
taken on the challenge with AI. We have
seen that people want to build with AI.
They want to build agentic applications.
They want to build agents that scale and
operate in a way that is very simple. We
want to make sure that every software
engineer right now is an AI engineer and
it is simple as attaching agents and AI
to your apps. So how are you doing that?
Currently a lot of solutions are only
for the day one problems. But what
happens on day two? How do you operate
it? How do you scale it? There are so
many models out there. How do you know
this is the right model for your
problem? How do you know your tools are
running safely? Heroku has taken a very
opinionated and curated set of models
that we believe work best for our
customers and developers will enjoy. We
have expanded that further by deeply
entrenching these models in an agentic
control loop that runs on Heroku that
has access to tools like code execution,
access to your data all under the trust
layer of Heroku. And for these extension
of agents, we are using the model
context protocol.
You might have seen online that people
keep asking that who's going to build
the hero of AI or who this is the heroku
of X. So the question for who's building
the hero of AI, it's Heroku of course.
Why wouldn't we?
Okay. So what are the challenges right
now people are facing? One of the things
that I can see is that how do you how do
you figure out that this model works
best for you? How do you know that it's
evaluated and traced and has the right
technologies to make sure that it is
performing the way you want it to
perform? So these are the challenges
that we're taking on. We are curating
these things such that whenever you work
with the agentic applications, you don't
feel like it's a bunch of knobs and
bells and whistles like a plane, but
it's actually pretty simple by taking on
that opinionated approach of having
those defaults for you. You can get
started with as simple as one CLI
command. you you just told Heroku AI
models create and that attaches AI to
your app as a resource.
U moving on to the next slide of course.
Okay. So we have three major things that
work great for a AI application or
building agentic applications. One is we
offer primitives like inference where
you can curate and take a set of models
and access this in your apps. We also
have model context protocol to extend
your apps. You can build remote MCP
servers on Heroku. simplified way and
you can also build standard IO MCP
servers that run in Heroku's trusted
compute and they can also scale to zero
so that you do not pay for things that
you're not using and we also have had PG
vector which is a great vector database
for your embeddings.
So all all these together give you all
the primitives that you need to build
agentic applications.
So how do we do this?
Heroku has a trusted comput layer called
dinos and the these compute is what the
one that runs tools for you. So example
we we provide first party tools like
code execution that run on Heroku's
compute and these can run on the compute
and stream the data back to you and
solve your problems. We plan to offer
our additional firstparty tools such as
web search for grounding uh memory.
Memory is really important right now. So
in the future it'll probably offer
memory and other compute tools that can
run on Herokus compute and provide to
you. You can bring your own tools as
well using MCP that can run on our
compute and stream things back to
agents.
Okay, with that I'll hand over to Julian
for a more hands-on workshop and you can
build all the things I spoke about
within the next 30 minutes. Okay, let's
go back to this last uh picture for the
folks that just joined so you get access
to the workshop content and remember we
have the Slack channel in the
ai.engineer workspace where I already
shared these slides and the link so you
can follow along you can follow along
with me right now or you can follow
along at home with more time.
So what are we going to do is the
following. So let me show you that link
is going to take you to this page.
In this page, you have access to the
workshop resources. This is a website
that has the instructions step by step
of what you are going to be doing today.
I'm going to be following these same
steps right here right now. And second,
we have a way for you to get access to
if you already have an EO account. Just
put your email, the email that you use
to log into. If you don't have one, go
and sign up first. You can sign up for
it. You don't need to enter your credit
card information. With just this
invitation, you are going to get access
to the workshop. These services are
going to be enabled until
uh the seventh like this weekend. And I
can extend it if you like the content we
have for you. This is going to send you
an invitation to a team. The the team is
called AI engineer worlds fair. go
accept that invitation and then you have
access to this dashboard. So from the
Heroku dashboard you go to
dashboard.heroku.com
you logged in and you should get access
to this view. We already have like some
pre-eployed applications here. The
workshop that I will be showing you, the
Jupiter notebook, the brave search MCP,
we are going to use a pre-existing MCP
to give you an example of how to call
that MCP from the manage inference and
agents endpoint. And I also have another
application here which is the AI
engineer data that has an AOKUP
posgressql database. And we are going to
see how can we build agents that has
access to this database as well. But we
start the workshop
first by deploying an Hokku application.
So we have this Heroku Jopter template
that you can deploy to Heroku. Go to the
repository
after you have the account and logged
into Heroku.
Just click to deploy.
Click to deploy it.
You are getting this uh page that will
ask you for an application name. Make
sure that this application name is
unique
and the internet situation is a little
bit slow. Let's hope it gets better
to show you that things work live.
Otherwise, I I need to start getting
access somewhere. If you join this mail,
please go to the Slack channel. It's
called workshop Heroku. Heroku AI. Yeah,
Heroku AI workshop. And in the AI
engineer Slack channel, you can find the
how to get started instructions. If you
guys are stuck somewhere or you don't
know how to get started, please raise
your hands and I can come help you out.
Beautiful. This is the deployment page.
We're going to create a new application.
Remember to have a like a unique name.
Let's do this is JDI Jupiter. This is
going to be my Jupiter. It is not
unique. So if it is not unique, you're
going to get an error. So let's do
workshop
to get a a unique. And for the app
owner, if you want this workshop to work
without you paying anything, make sure
to select the AI engineer war,
which is the team we have invited you
to.
These uh Jupyter notebooks are password
protected. So there is an environment
variable here for you to define the
password to this workshop. I'm going to
use a super secure password lab and then
click to deploy. So this is going to
deploy the application with a u dyno
where the Jupyter notebook is going to
run. The dyno is pretty much the
container unit with your application
runs like the virtual machine on Heroku
and it also has heroku posgress. So all
the work that you are going to do in the
Jupyter notebook is going to get
persisted into this database and this is
going to take a little bit of time to to
install. This is pretty much uh fetching
all the source code of this Jupyter
notebook uh template to Heroku building
that application and all of the
dependencies and then you have this
available for you to use.
So basically you are going to get
something like this. I already have this
deployed but you don't have any workshop
here. So we are going to be loading that
notebook
and to load that notebook you go and
keep following the instructions. Oh the
third step that I miss is how can we
provision manage inference ma mainly how
can we pro provision an AI model to an
AOKU application.
So manage inference is a service that
let you run AI models within the same
infrastructure where your application is
running. So the data is not going to
third parties. If you are using let's
say like open AI or anthropic APIs the
data is going outside your application.
This is keeping uh everything running
inside the same network that your
application is running. And to provision
this, you can use the Heroku CLI, but we
are going to make things easy. Once the
application is deployed, this is taking
uh time to deploy. So let's go to
something that it's already deployed.
Let's say this one that I I already uh
created before.
You go to your application in the
dashboard. You click to uh the
management page. Then you go to
resources.
And in resources is where you can
provision add-ons. Add-ons like Heroku
posgress or the key value store or any
other thirdparty add-on that we support
on our marketplace. The one that we are
going to provision is called Heroku
manage inference and agents. This is our
AI offering. So you are going to click
on this add-on and then you will select
the model that you want to use in your
application. We support textto text
models from entropic cloud 3.5 3.7 and
4. We support coher embed for embeddings
and we support a stable image ultra for
image generation. We are going to be
working mostly with textto text with
inference model. So let's do cloud 4.
We submit
and that's it. Now my application can
access
AI services. That's the only thing that
you need to do. And how this works, this
is going to enable your application to
have access to environment variables
that contain the API URL, the API key,
and the model ID. And with those three
things, you can use like an existing SDK
that supports the Open AI specification
or the OpenAI API or you can perform
like an HTTP request or build your own
solution to uh run these applications.
So now we provision AI into our app.
Now our another app is deployed. So we
can do the same with that. So I'm going
to keep following. Then let's go and
load the workshop. So I'm going to be
copying this URL. That's the Jupiter
notebook we are going to load on our
Jupiter template that we deploy. And
here you go to file, open from URL. You
paste that URL. Click on open. And
voila, we have our uh notebook ready to
start.
So remember that we provision the manage
inferent and agent service into our
application that is going to give us
three environment variables. If I go
here to settings
reveal config bars we see the
environment variables there the
inference key the model ID and the
inference URL the API key that we will
use to call the service.
So obviously the first step that we will
do is to load those environment
variables on our Jupiter environment. So
we will do this workshop in four parts.
The first one is set up the environment.
We are going to just load those
environment variables so we can continue
doing our activities. Second we are
performing manage inference. This is
your basic chat completions endpoint and
we will see two examples. one doing like
basic chat completions and the other one
doing a streaming version of those chat
completions endpoint. The third which is
one of my favorite ones is the Heroku
tools or the agents part. We have
another endpoint that lets you run
agents that we support natively. We have
code execution agents. We have database
access agents, document conversion, uh
execute commands on a dyno and we are
going to continue adding more to those
and this is just an endpoint that
performs the execution of the agent in
the Heroku infrastructure in our dinos
and it is just an one of dyno. What is a
one-off dyno? It just spin ups, runs the
code and it scales back to zero. So you
are not paying for an application that
is constantly running. you are just
paying for the amount of compute that
that tool took to execute. And that
endpoint also support MCPs. MCPS that
you can deploy to Heroku
and then attach them to your H inference
agent endpoint. And last but not least,
we are going to take a look at that MCP
support that we have. How can you deploy
an MCP to Heroku, attach that MCP to the
agents endpoint and also use those MCPS
externally remotely through the MCP
gateway or MCP toolkits that we have. I
know it sounds like a lot, but it's
going to be easy. I have a couple of
exercises for you if you want to write
some code, but basically what I would be
doing here is just like running the code
that I already have implemented here. My
good friend. Thank you for coming. Okay,
so first thing I told you we need to
load these three environment variables
inference URL, inference key and
inference model ID. And there is a
fourth one that we will use for certain
uh tool execution on AOKU which is the
target application name. So what are
going to put you here in target
application name? the name of the
application you deploy. the name of the
application the Heroku the the Heroku
Jupyter application that you deploy in
this case my work my Jupyter notebook is
called AI engineer workshop this is the
one that I'm going to use here I am
giving permission to my tool to run
commands and perform compute operations
on this dyno on this application so here
you just replace to the name of your
application so you can do those examples
And later I will show you also how can
you give access to the application that
has the database to run the other
examples that we have for you. So let's
uh load the environment variables.
Now the environment variables are ready
so I can continue with the examples.
Then let's go with manage inference. I
mentioned that for manage inference we
have the basic chat completions
endpoint. This is an endpoint that you
will find on services like OpenAI or
Cloudantropic. Basically, you ask a
question, you send a message or an array
of messages and you are going to get a
response. This endpoint also supports
custom tool execution, but this tool
execution is something that is happening
on your code. So, you need to specify
the function and capture like the
information to execute those. Or if you
are using an agent framework like ADK or
lang chain, it also has like custom tool
execution internally. But for the
example, we are going to perform a basic
inference. To perform the basic
inference, we are we are going to do a
basic HTTP request. So we have the
inference key, the model ID on the
payload. So we are going to use cloud 4
which is the model that I provision here
on my app and the message that I'm going
to send as an user is explain the cont
the concept of manage inference in one
sentence you can adjust the parameters
that the open AI API supports like
temperature maximum tokens top P etc.
You can take a look at the documentation
by clicking on the uh path endpoint and
it will take you to the documentation of
that endpoint and lot of the parameters
we support
and then after performing the HTTP
request we get the response as JSON and
let's run this
and let's see how this work.
So we get a response like any other AI
endpoint works. So we have a chat
completions object with the different
choices like the amount of messages that
it returns. Basically we have just one
message here as an assistant and the
response is manage inference is a cloud
service that handles the deployment
scaling and maintenance of machine
learning models for real-time
predictions etc. So that's a basic
example. So this is something that you
can do everywhere getting inference it
became a commodity and also to show that
we also support the streaming of course
we want to have like a better experience
uh while building our applications we
need to support streaming meaning that
is not going to return the whole answer
as just one JSON object is going to
start giving you chunks so you can get
that real time feedback when getting the
response from the inference service. So
here I'm just consuming chunks and
printing out those chunks on the s uh on
the screen. The first example is going
just to show you the raw version of this
request.
So this is using a server send event
approach is sending you message events.
Every message events has data and each
data is a piece of that completion
object. But in this case you are getting
like a like a delta like a version of
that message. So you see here in the
content we get nothing then streaming is
crucial for this and then it continues
giving me the response. We get a bunch
of different responses but let's take a
look how that looks like on an
application when you are rendering the
chunks. This is just the pure objects to
understand how the API works. Here I
have another example where I am doing
some parsing of that information
extracting the delta content of each
response and then at the end rendering
everything as a beautiful markdown. When
I execute this the inference service is
going to start responding on real time
chunk by chunk all the messages that I'm
getting from the service. As you can see
it is a markdown response. So at the end
when we finish we use the markdown uh
display object here in Jupiter to get
the beautiful answer here. Sometimes it
will give you like a a code example
depending of what the inference uh
service is giving you and that's how
this works and how this is how you can
build an application to consume these
real time streams.
But now let's talk about the good part
which is the agents.
Who has built an agent before? Like an
application that executes a tool or run
some code. Perfect. We have like couple
hands there. Amazing. So the tools that
we support today and Anush here as
product manager can tell us what we are
going to be supporting in the future are
uh dino run command. Dino run command
allows you to execute a command on a
dynino like a Unix command or a script
that you are do you already have
pre-eployed on your application it will
execute that and give you the response
so this is pretty good to run trusted
code code that you have written that you
know that it works that it has a
predictive um uh predictive result and
you can just have that code running on
your dyno and executed through this A
this agent this tool we have query
databases we have two tools here one is
posgress get a schema and the other one
is posgress run query posgress get a
schema mean the llms doesn't know the
shape of your database if you ask for
data it will hallucinate an SQL query or
if you have some sort of retrieve
augmented generation or if you are
grounding the prompt with the shape of
your database is it will generate
something that it's close to the shape
of the data of your database. But with
this tool, it will get exactly what you
have on the on the database and then we
can pass that schema to the next tool
which is run query. It will generate a
query that will run on your database,
get the result and make inference over
those uh data. Then we have a couple
other tools for document transformation.
HTML to markdown, PDF to markdown. You
pass an URL like a website or a URL of a
PDF that is hosted somewhere and it will
give you the markdown response. So the
inference can work over that text
content. It's going to perform that text
extraction for you. And my favorites are
the code execution one. We support four
today. Python, Node, Ruby and Go. So the
LLM will generate code that will run on
Heroku on a one of dyno and it will
return that response back to the
inference service and these also support
dependency installation. So the input
parameter has like a a packages array
parameter where the lm automatically say
okay my python script is going to use
pandas or numpy let's install it before
I attempt to execute the tool and all of
these are just MCPS that we natively
support but you can also extend this
agent endpoint by deploying your own
your own MCPS so now let's take a The
agent's endpoint is different to the
chat completions. It works similarly
with some minor differences. For
example, all of the responses are a
stream. So it doesn't support like the
synchronous call where it waits to give
you like the full response because code
execution access to database and this
tool execution take time. So we prefer
to have it like a stream and um
depending of the tool you are using you
might need to give access to the tool to
your database
or to an application for example to
execute a command. So let's try that
first one. Let's run a demo to run a
command on an eroku dynino.
So here we are setting up the payload
similar to chat completions. We have the
model ID. We have the message. We are
asking
what is the current date and time on the
server. LLN doesn't know anything about
like the real time. They need to use
tools to be able to have context about
what's going on right now. I have asked
the LLM about like information and it
gives me like information from 2024
because that's the date when they stop
training that model. But with this, it
knows exactly what time is because it's
running this command on the server. So
the tool is an AOKU tool. So I'm
specifying the type to run this on AOKU.
The tool that I'm executing is the Dino
run command. And then the parameters for
this tool are okay. The target app name,
remember I told you use the name of the
application you deploy. And then the
command to run is date. and a
description of pretty much what's going
on with the with the output of this uh
command
and I'm calling it I'm just calling the
agents AOKU endpoint. I'm passing that
payload that has the tool. This is also
a streamed endpoint. So I'm having the
the stream output here and I'm just
extracting the tool calls and this is a
standard also shape like API shape that
other uh API support for tool calling
but this is specifically running the
tools onu. So let's execute and see the
example and I'm hoping you can execute
these two in your in your Jupyter
notebook. So it is running this on my AI
engineer workshop application. It's
going to execute the dyno run command.
So now it is waiting until it runs the
command on my app. We get the the date
and time and then the inference
response.
Cool. I mean it's a basic example but
powerful. Instead of running date,
imagine if you deploy your own script
that does your data extraction or
connects to external services, you can
just call it call it from here from this
endpoint as well. The other one code
execution
uh with code execution I am asking the
inference service to perform a operation
and I am passing that code execution
tool. So now that it has that tool
enabled, it will try to generate code in
that language, run it on au and give you
the response back. For this example, I
will invite you to change node to
python, ruby or go to see different uh
responses. I'm a node developer even
though I have a bunch of python here.
Some of you might recognize this is llm
generated. So sorry, not sorry. That's
what tools are for. And I'm going to be
executing that codeex node to perform
this operation. What is the 30th
Fibonacci number? This is a basic
algorithm. I just wanted to do something
uh easy. I will invite you to change
this to perform a different operation
and see what you can do like break this
thing. And then for the execution I am
just parsing the response. So I get like
beautiful uh markdown code highlighting
and everything.
So let's perform the operation
and um
it will generate uh the algorithm.
Let's see. Okay, I will execute codeexc
node. This is the code that I'm passing
as the input. This is the beautiful
markdown syntax highlight code that it
will execute. That's JavaScript. Yes,
that's JavaScript
and at the end it's going to execute
that code on Heroku and then I am
getting the response back. The Fibonacci
number is 233
but I want to do that in go. So just
change
from no to go
execute this
and it will do the same but now the code
that we are going to see here is a is a
go code and it will do the same. get
this go code on an eroku dino, compile
it, run it, and get you the response
back. That looks like a go code to me. I
am not not a go developer, but that
definitely looks like go and it execute
the response and it gave me the same
thing and an explanation like the
inference operation over that tool
execution.
But that's cool. So far, we have just
called one tool. The good thing about
agents is that we can chain calls
together, mix and match. We we have like
different agents acting together. So now
let's complicate things a little bit
more and we are going to use two tools.
One is the HTML to markdown. So go to a
website do something and then get that
result and use it on this other agent.
For that we are going to use two tools
HTML to markdown and code execution
Python.
So the prompt here is use the Python
snippet from the Wikipedia page for
Ukidian algorithm to calculate the
common divisor of 200 uh 252 and 105.
So it doesn't know the algorithm. I am
telling directly go fetch the exact one
that it's on Wikipedia then run this
code on AOA and give me the response.
I'm enabling those two tools HTML to
markdown and code execution Python
and let's run this and now we are going
to see multiple tool calling getting the
page in markdown. So now it recognized
that the Uklidian algorithm page is this
one. Now it is reading the whole content
of that page in markdown attempting to
get the algorithm from there. Then it's
going to generate the code. Then it's
going to run the code and at the end I'm
going to get the response. This
execution takes a little bit more time
because it is performing multiple uh
tool runs at the same time.
Any questions so far? Is anybody doing
it? If not, you have access to the
workshop. you can do it uh at home with
more time, modify the code, analyze it
and make sure uh the concept is
understood. So it got the algorithm here
and it execute the thing on Heroku. Now
I'm just waiting for the last inference
step and that execution is done. There
you go. I found the Python
implementation from Wikipedia. I
calculate that number that you asked me.
This is the Python snippet from
Wikipedia
and then it implemented in this code and
this is how I did it. These are the
explanation. Beautiful. It works.
Now before I get into posgress
execution,
we need to have access to the database.
And right now the application that you
have doesn't have access to that
database. If you want to give it a try,
you are going to go to
the Heroku dashboard.
Where is the Heroku dashboard? Here
to the AI engineer worldphere.
Click on AI engineer data.
Go to resources.
And we have one thing here. The posgress
database tools only work on followers.
Followers on Heroku are read only for
security reasons. We don't want to give
an LLM tool right access to your
database because of course uh LLMs are
not trusted for that. If you want to
give right access to your production
database to an agent, I will invite you
to deploy an MCP that does that like the
posgrsql MCP give the access under your
own risk. The ones we maintain, we want
to make sure we don't like break
production. So we have two different
databases here. The master one or the
main one is database. Don't touch that
one. The other one that has attachments
is the follower. So you are going to
expand this manage attachments
and add your application
like
Julian Jupiter and that's it. Now I gave
my application access to the database.
Second
you will need to get the name of that
database. So go to your application
in this case is uh Julian Jupiter
go to resources
and this database here
AI engineer data
in my application is called database. So
that's the name I'm going to use in
code.
Since I am working on AI um AI engineer
workshop, the name is different. So I'm
going to show you so you can rec
recognize the differences in names. This
is just the name of the environment
variable on Heroku that has the
connection string.
So here I have access to that database
on this application. My database is
called Heroku PosgrSQL Aqua. So that's
the name you are going to give and
change it in your code
possql aqua.
So now I have access to that specific
database on my app. I cannot access
databases from other applications. This
is for security reasons. So this is why
I have to do the attachment first to be
able to give permissions to my database.
If the database lives in your
application, you don't need to do do
this because your application already
has access to it. That's the only thing
that we need to do here to to set up. Uh
then
we are going to enable two tools
posgress get a schema and posgress run
query. These are going to run on my
application. Remember the target app
name and these are going to access that
specific database. So I'm giving
permission to go to those two uh places.
So the database that we have here is a
database for a solar energy company. It
contains a table full of metrics with uh
energy consumed and energy produced
every hour in kilowatts per hour and we
have metrics for maybe two months. So
now what type of applications can we
build with this like asking questions
like how much energy has been saved in
the last 30 days.
It's going to understand the shape of
the database. It will see that it has a
metrics table with these columns. Then
it will go and generate an SQL query to
be able to get this information and then
run that query and give you the
response.
and let's execute that to see how it
works.
So first step is I don't understand your
database let me get the schema.
So to get the schema it executes the
tool and then you are going to see the
full schema being printed here on the
screen in a moment. So now we have the
schema of my database.
it see the different tables metrics with
the fields
uh products systems users etc. So I have
the information that I need here.
Beautiful. Now it will run the the
query. So it already generated the query
that it is 100% sure will run on my
database because it knows the shape.
This is the response. It got the data.
And now that after it got the data, it's
going to perform the inference. It's
going to extract the answer from that
data and at the end it's going to tell
me the information.
it wanted to run more queries to get a
breakdown of the energy by system. I
have three different systems. One system
that performs well, the other one that
doesn't perform pretty good, the other
one that it's totally horrible. So, it
is also trying to get more information
just from one one question. It is doing
inference on my data. And I just enabled
two tools. I didn't need to do anything
else. And there we go. the report. These
are the key metrics. This is how much
you have saved. And this is the
breakdown per system. The best
performer, good performer and the energy
deficit. And this is G getting access to
your data and acting over your data. We
can add a third tool. Let's say code
execution Python. I want to generate a
graphic. So it will now do a mattplot
leap uh graphic with that data. and you
can keep adding more more things but
also the more agents and tools that you
add it will take more time to perform
the whole operation but that's an
example how can you mix and match these
tools that we have here and uh how can
you give access to agents to your data I
have a couple of exercises
just try to come up with an example to
use a PDF and extract something from
that PDF and run code and you can do
this on your own time. We are running
low on code. I want to show you now how
can we
deploy and run MCPs with this same
endpoint. So those are the tools we
maintain. But what about the tools you
are building and the tools that already
exist on the MCP ecosystem.
So with manage manage inference and
agents
uh let's say you go to the dashboard to
the configuration page and here
you get access to the um model
configuration
and here it has the toolkit integration
and the MCP server list. So basically
this MCP brave that I have here the
brave search MCP and you might have
already have access to this or you can
attach it to your own Jupyter notebook.
Pretty much to attach an MCP you click
on manage MCP servers. You attach it as
an application similar to what we did
with the database. It's just another
application and there you go. We have an
MCP server here that is exposing two
tools. web search and local search. So
now we can use these tools on the agents
endpoint. So let me go and take a look
at that. So these are the instructions
step by step how can you enable an MCP.
Then
it's just another tool.
This time it is not a Heroku tool. It is
just an MCP. And this is the name of the
tool that I will execute.
MCP brave
is the name of the name space. You can
have multiple MCPS here. So this is kind
of like an like a name space for your
MCPS.
And I am going to execute brave web
search. This requires an API key. And I
already have the API key on my
application. If you want, you can go
ahead and take it. I'm going to like
remove that API key in a moment. Don't
perform like a 2,00 queries otherwise I
I'm going to get uh charged
but now I have access to it and the
security to also enable those those keys
to your MCPS and I will execute it as
another tool and the prompt that I'm
sending is what is the most recent news
about the AI agents. Let's execute this
tool.
And this MCP is running on Heroku. The
same thing as code execution or the
posgress uh tools. It will spin off a
dyno. Run the MCP as a standard input
and output and scale back to zero. So
you are not paying for something that is
constantly running. And there we go.
That's the search from the Brave web
search. So this is the response from the
tool and now it's going to uh render
that after the inference uh operation.
So I'm running MCPS on Heroku. A quick
example, how can you deploy an MCP?
I have uh an exercise here. Deploy an
MCP to Hokku. I have a perplexity ask
MCP that I just forked.
This is the official perplexity MCP. I
fork it to my repository to just do one
thing to make it compatible. You use the
prog file which is the file on AOKU that
defines how an application is executed
and I added the entry point as an MCP.
So this is a new process type we
support. Everything that starts with MCP
is going to be recognized as an MCP on
Heroku. It will execute this standard
input an output code. It also requires
an API key that I don't have, but you
can deploy it. To deploy to Heroku, I
added a button to make it super easy.
Click to deploy. I deploy this uh MCP to
my space and then I attach it to my
application. This is my perplexity
MCP.
Let's add it available to the space.
I don't have one.
I deploy. There are certain MCPS. If you
don't have an API key, it fails when you
run them. So, this is why I'm specifying
something. It doesn't need to be valid.
And this is now a Node.js application.
It will just deploy this, build this,
and keep it available on aqua and you
will be able to attach it to your to
your app. So this is an exercise you can
do and write the code to run that that
MCP that you just deployed.
Now we got the response from the
previous uh brave search
and this is pretty much the most recent
news about AI agents.
But remember that I told you that you
can also use those MCPS outside of
Heroku, not only for EOU agents. Let's
say you are using Corsor or cloud
desktop or you are writing your own
agent in a different platform but you
want to have those MCPs available
remotely you can use those two. So here
on the management dashboard you see the
toolkit integration page. So all of the
MCPS that I deploy to my app are going
to be available through this endpoint.
So this is a server send event endpoint
and it is um authenticated behind a
better token and we are working on oout
support. We're getting remote as well so
that you can run it securely. You can
build remote MCP servers on Heroku that
are accessible without your beer tokens.
We don't like bearer tokens. Perfect. So
now that the MCP is there, let's add
like my my perplexity really quick.
Let's refresh.
I need it. Perfect. I have it. It's
available. I go to my toolkit, copy the
token. It is the same the same token
that you use for inference. So I don't
need to do this. You just need the URL.
And in my Jupiter code, I have a basic
MCP client I'm using.
So I need to install the dependency
here. I'm using the MCP package from
uh from Entropic
and I'm creating an MCP client. That MCP
client is going to my AOKU endpoint
passing that API key as a authorization
header and let's run it to list the
tools that are available and then
execute brave web search. So, I'm
executing the MCP that I deploy in
Heroku outside of Heroku.
Let's run this demo.
And it connected. We have the following
tools. Brave local search, Brave web
search, and perplexity ask the one that
we just deployed and enabled with just
two clicks mostly. And it executed the
web search. I am not processing the
result here. This is just a very basic
example, but that's how can you deploy
an MCP and use it externally. And I
think and I I have also like a corsor
uh MCP gateway that I use for MCPS that
I deploy. I just use the same approach
to use my MCPS and Corser.
And last but not least, uh I told you
that the at least the chat completion
endpoint is compatible with OpenAI API.
95% we are working to bring it to 99%
like certain parameters that are not
supported but you can just use the SDK
so let's use the SDK to perform a basic
operation I am just using the open AI
SDK with the API key and URL from AOKU
I perform an inference
and we should get a response
in a moment.
And there you go. We have the response.
And that's pretty much what we had for
you today. You get access to this
notebook. Keep playing with it. I
extended access to to the Heroku
platform that team until the weekend
because right now, unfortunately, we
don't have a free tier. We are working
hard to bring it back. Uh but you can go
deploy, try it out and if you have any
questions, please um uh connect with us
on social.
Uh we have um the dev center docu site
for documentation,
the Heroku AAI website. Uh we created a
Heroku community on Twitter or X. These
slides are on the Slack, so you can get
them from the Slack. And thank you very
much. I hope you enjoyed this worship.
[Applause]
[Music]